what's up everyone my name is tara
roberts here in the bleacher report app
you can find me on twitter at it's terra
time and today we are walking through
the perfect first round we are doing 12
picks 1 through 12 in ppr one
quarterback and i'm gonna be picking as
if i were taking a pic from every single
position in the first round and talk
through who i'm gonna pick at every
single one um before we get started guys
i'll just go through some quick players
that i am currently loving um based off
the preseason and things that i've been
seeing over the past week
obviously um the big one for me is jalen
hurts
he actually had a fantastic year last
year when he started off the season um
and then things kind of went sideways
once the eagles committed to run but
they've really been investing in the
past and i'm really loving what i'm
seeing from him he had a great first
drive on that preseason game last week
so
loving jalen hurts trey lance also
looked fantastic we've got travis ctn
who is back and maybe going to have a
kind of interesting
competition there with um with james
robinson in the backfield
it's going to be very very interesting
and
i also like damian pierce as well out of
the texans i'm actually in houston right
now so hopefully damian pierce can be
there to kind of help pick things up a
little bit
um some other guys that i'm seeing brian
robinson is kind of an interesting one
is a late uh round swing because we've
seen that maybe he's going to be taking
over some of that workload from antonio
gibson
um it's going to be very interesting to
see what's going to happen over there
we've heard from ron rivera that they do
want to split the workload there between
them so
um yeah those are a few of the guys that
i'm seeing that are some pre-season
stands out so that you might want to go
ahead and grab but
i see a lot of people joining in to the
chat we've got a great audience here so
let's go ahead and let's get started
we're going to start off so if you guys
see in the top corner top right corner
over there we've got a clock we're
actually going to have a real clock as
i'm talking through these first picks
and let's go ahead and kick it off let's
go ahead and kick it off and see what
we're going to do at the 101 clock has
started
you might think that this is going to be
an incredibly easy pick and you know
what quite frankly kind of it is for me
but i will debate it out because there
are a couple of different directions you
could go here
obviously we've got jonathan taylor
typically out of the 101 you want to go
ahead and get a stud running back
jonathan taylor was that guy last year
and i do think that he's going to repeat
this year as well when we look at him
last year he had 1800 yards 18
touchdowns
5.5 yards per carry so he didn't just
have an incredibly high workload he was
incredibly talented and incredibly
efficient while doing it he also had a
decent amount of receptions as well with
40 receptions over 300 yards a couple of
touchdowns
average fantasy points 21.9 points per
game um it was an absolutely fantastic
year now we do have christian mccaffrey
who has typically been the 101 out of
that position so there's that direction
that you could go as well
um
i'm a little bit risk adverse with
christian mccaffrey i get a little bit
concerned because this has been two
seasons in a row that we've had injuries
that have literally if you picked him
might have actually tanked your fantasy
season so
in my opinion i am going to use the 101
to go with the smash guarantee of
jonathan taylor he is a true workhorse
running back he is young he is talented
he literally has no negative marks on
his resume he's a fantastic option to
take at the 101.
out of the 102.
here's another one where i get a little
bit controversial so
here
we have a couple of different options we
can go with i still want to go with
running back i know it's tempting to
want to go ahead and dive right into the
wide receivers because we do have some
fantastic options at wide receiver
but i'm going to keep on the running
back train we've got a few options that
we can go with here we've obviously got
austin eckler we've got derek henwey
we've got christian mccaffrey that we
talked about as well three very solid
high upside running backs that you could
go with
for me
this is where i differ from a lot of
people a lot of people if they're not
taking christian mccaffrey at the 101
they're taking him at the 102 i am not
doing that we're going to go ahead and
nix christian mccaffrey out of this
option for me
and i'm narrowing it down to austin
eckler and derrick henry and this is a
really tough decision because again
we've got two running backs who
yeah they are a little bit older in
terms of workload i think that's why you
defer to jonathan taylor at the 101
but
i am going to go with out of the 102
austin eckler and i'm going to explain
why real quick i'm going to dispel a few
of the myths here really quick um again
the age concern a lot of people get
worried because he is 27 years old and
that typically tends to be a cutoff when
things start to get a little shaky
especially with running backs that are a
little bit smaller but you have to
remember that austin eckler doesn't
really have a very high workload on him
the first three years of his career he
actually had
less carries total over the first three
years of his career than najee harris
literally had last year alone
so austin eckler he is one of my
favorite picks to take out of the 102
particularly in ppr
very high upside um guys we are going to
let me see if we've got some stuff from
the chat uh yes
we've got a comment here from at t-e-b-r
atlanta falcons year baby
i love the atlanta falcons um i'm
actually from i'm in houston right now
but i am originally from south carolina
about an hour and a half out from
atlanta and there's some fantastic
options in atlanta if you want to go
with kyle pitts who obviously top three
tight end fantastic option to take um
probably as you're heading in around the
third round or so
um we've got another comment here from
croc 7676
king henry cmc can't stay healthy i
agree
i agree with you you'll see um in these
next couple of picks whether or not i
defer to going with derek henry over
christian mccaffrey because
again we'll talk about it a little bit i
see another comment here from at raj uh
yeah cmc gonna slide a bit
absolutely he is sliding a bit a lot of
you know i see a lot of analysts that
still have him up there at the 101 at
the 102. i personally don't do that just
because
for me it's a little bit too risky to go
ahead and take them in those spots i
prefer to take some people that i think
are a little more solid guarantees to
make it through the entire year so i
completely agree with you um i see
another comment here from emat
yeah say on a fifth or sixth rounder i'm
actually seeing sequon come in a little
bit higher than that um
i uh if you can get sequan in the fifth
or sixth round absolutely 100 take him
there that would be fantastic value
last year we saw sequon um coming off of
that injury he was a little bit shaky
but this year he's fully recovered we're
hearing that he's going to be having his
full workload he's obviously going to
have a ton of reception work out of the
backfield
and he is unchallenged there is
literally nobody else out there that is
going to be able to compete with him on
the team so he is the young question rb1
on that team um saquon has a lot of
upside this year
guys let's dive back into this third
pick and let's see what we're gonna take
here
get the clock started here we go
now we had a comment um regarding derek
henry versus christian mccaffrey and
let's go ahead and debate this out
because
this is the perfect spot to do so i feel
a lot sick i feel very safe with
jonathan taylor
austin eckler again we talk through it
he's actually a very safe pick
he's not actually injury prone he is a
good workload got high upside in terms
of ppr
out of the third spot here is where we
dive into those running backs who do
have more of those injury concerns um
derek henry let's talk about him for a
little bit
now last year this was the first time
we'd really seen a kind of major issue
with derek henry that took him out for
half the year but let's talk about the
time that he was actually on the field
derek henry he was a he was literally
the rb1 we look at we look at jonathan
taylor in the year that he had and it
was fantastic we talked about his
fantasy points the average 21.9 fantasy
points per game in ppr a lot of times we
think about derek henry that he might be
that guy who you might not want to take
in ppr maybe standard maybe half ppr
no in ppr last year derek henry actually
averaged 24.2
fantasy points per game in the games
that he played in
he is my rb3 i am taking derrick henry
off the board right here over cmc so you
guys all of you that said you had a
little bit concerns with cmc completely
agree with you you're on track right
there we are taking derrick henry out of
the 103.
gonna be a fantastic opt-in
now
we're heading into the 104.
here's where things start to get a
little bit muddied because you could
dive into the receivers we've got a lot
of high upside receivers here with
cooper cup justin jefferson jamar chase
three fantastic options that i am 100
taking in the first round
but
i still think that we could squeeze in
another running back here and now that
we've got jonathan taylor off the board
we've got austin eckler off the board
we've got derek henry off the board
now is the time
that i feel a little bit more
comfortable jumping in
and going with christian mccaffrey
let's talk about christian mccaffrey for
a second he is an incredibly
risky pick it's incredibly risky when
you've got an rb1 that might not make it
through the entire season we've seen it
we've seen it in 2019 we've seen it in
2020 we've seen it 2021 where we get a
little bit concerned for the past two
years about whether or not he's going to
actually be able to make it through the
season but the thing about christian
mccaffrey and where you do have to take
some risk and you you do have to take
him at some point in the first round
when he plays when he's healthy
he typically is going to be the overall
rb1 in ppr
i know we have some concerns there with
the carolina panthers they've got a
shaky quarterback situation but it does
look like baker mayfield is going to be
getting the starting job
and at this point at the 104 i feel a
lot more comfortable taking christian
mccaffrey before i dive into some of
those running backs like
dalvin cook that has some injury
concerns as well uh najee harris that
has some teen concerns and maybe some
workload concerns as well so at the 104
we're going to go ahead and take
christian mccaffrey now guys
let me dive back into the chat and see
we have some questions over here and see
some comments we've got from bq king
naje jerry henry will die out we'll talk
about najee in a second i
we'll see
we'll see where i take him i do love
nadia harris i don't think that uh derek
henry is going to die out i understand
your concerns i do
because we talk about a 28 year old
running back who's got uh almost 7 000
career yards
and a little bit of a shaky situation
maybe there as well
with the
lack of the receiving core now that aj
brown is gone that's a little bit of a
concern i'm not too concerned about that
because we've actually had a couple of
games last year where aj brown was out
and derek henry was still highly
productive over 100 yards in both of
those games so
i'm okay with it
um
comment from nick connolly cmc extremely
risky though yeah he is which is why i'm
discounting it to the 104 you do have to
discount it technically i would prefer
maybe to just kind of avoid christian
mccaffrey and
it be somebody else's problem within the
first round but you can't let him slide
out of the first round is the problem
because if someone was getting christian
mccaffrey in the second round
that would be absolutely insane so he
does have to come off the board at some
point and i think at the 104 later is an
appropriate time for him
now we've got a comment here from brain
sr
i don't like eckler this much uh eckler
this year as much i actually like henry
or cook over eckler and i get what
you're saying over there i get what
you're saying because you know we can
talk about eckler again for a second
here
one of the things that people get a
little bit concerned with with austin
eckler is the possibility that he's
going to see touchdown regression that
was a career year for him in 2021. not
gonna lie on that one it was incredible
but if you actually dive into the
statistics of comparing his prior years
to 2021
everything is on track with his career
pace
the receiving yards track to prior years
the receiving touchdowns track to prior
years
even the rushing yardage and average
yards per carry that all tracked with
his prior years
excuse me guys that i'll track with his
prior year in terms of his 2020 pace as
well so i don't have any concerns about
any of that workload the only thing that
we have to be concerned about there with
austin eckler is that touchdown
regression of rushing touchdowns on the
ground
now
let's say that it goes from 12 to 8.
let's say there's a little bit of
regression that statistically is still
going to be a top three back so he's got
some room to work with if he can repeat
all of the other stats that are all
tracking and not really outliers i don't
think it's a major issue
all right now um one more comment before
we dive back in cup next from keegan
reaper
i kind of agree with you let's talk it
out let's dive into wide receiver as we
go into
the
105. we'll turn back on the clock
yes
i'm definitely going to take a receiver
here now that i've got all of these high
upside running backs out of the way but
the question is
are we taking cooper cup
are we taking justin jefferson
those are the two guys that we've got to
debate between because arguably they're
very close together and let's talk it
out why let's look out and say um let's
talk about cooper cup stats from 2021
obviously it was one of the most epic
seasons of all time 145 receptions on
191 targets that is absolutely insane
nearly 2 000 yards 16 touchdowns
is that actually repeatable
maybe not because it is an incredibly
epic season i don't know if we will see
that again
but
even if it's hard to repeat
he is the wide receiver one until he is
officially dethroned yeah 100 we are
going with cooper cup at the 105 over
justin jefferson sorry justin jefferson
but we have to defer to the current king
at wide receiver
now i know there are some concerns that
people might have
um
one of the concerns is matthew
stafford's injury now
it doesn't seem like that is going to be
something that would really make
stafford sit out as much it's just going
to be a pain management situation so
outside that i don't really have any
major concerns for cooper cup so i'm
really comfortable taking him at the
105.
now
let's see we've got a comment here from
four deuce who should i take at number
three overall assuming
jt eckler off the board
good question
again on that one i feel really
comfortable going with derek henry um if
you want to go with christian mccaffrey
there because you want to take the
upside i get that i just feel more
comfortable with derek henry and the
workload that he's going to have in that
offense and i don't think that that
injury is indicative of him being
someone that is unfortunately going to
be seeing a downslide this year the
workload is going to be there even if
they stack the box it is derek henry he
is still going to be a fantastic option
all right
at the number six spot i kind of tipped
my hat here as i'm debating between
cooper cup and justin jefferson so
i think you guys know where i'm heading
on this one but
we'll talk it out you could dive back
into running back there are some options
there we had you know several comments
there mentioning najee harris who is
someone
who again had a fantastic year last year
from a production standpoint you've got
dalvin cook who is always a high upside
option
you could go with joe mixon as well but
again i really like taking these wide
receivers off the board early
so after cooper cuck
i want to go with justin jefferson and
you know i'm deferring to cooper cup as
the wide receiver one but when i say it
is extremely close hear me out is
extremely close and the biggest reason
is
justin jefferson is stealing kevin
o'connell from cooper cup we're going to
see that same offense that cooper cup
thrived in and i think we even heard a
comment
over the past week from justin jefferson
saying that he saw exactly why cooper
cup was so incredibly successful in that
offense
so when we look at what he did last year
108 receptions compared to 145 to cooper
cup
the sky is the limit here for justin
jefferson and what he will be able to do
in this new offense here so at the 106 i
am 100 taking justin jefferson
now again as we head into this 107 pick
there are some options we can play
we're on a wide receiver one here a ride
receiver run here we could go with wide
receiver we could go with my wide
receiver 3 jamar chase it's not a bad
option he is a little bit riskier of a
pick um
but
there are a lot of fantastic options
here at running back that we can start
to go with these guys that are slipping
into the back half of round one
that are you know they've got a little
bit of concerns in terms of whether or
not they have the upside or maybe
they're in shaky situations but they are
still fantastic rb1 options that are
smash picks in the late round the guys
i'm talking about here are nausea harris
dalvin cook and joe mixon those are the
running backs that i look out to round
out the back half of my round one and
honestly they're all incredibly close
and
there's a lot that we can talk about in
terms of debating here
but at seven um
i'm gonna go ahead and i'm probably
gonna go with someone
that i feel like has a very stable
workload someone that i know we talked
about him is going to get
or had over 300 carries now we've heard
some news that they want to reduce the
workload on this guy that i'm taking
here
naja harris
but you don't have to be concerned about
that there's really no major competition
there they just want to kind of get him
out
of the lineup on
downs that might not really need him or
might not have a opportunity for him to
really be highly productive so
i'm going with naji harris here again
i think with the steelers you know we've
got some
situation where ben roethlisberger has
retired and
ben roethlisberg actually greatly
benefited
sorry guys ben roethlisberger actually
greatly benefited najee harris because
he threw the ball a ton in terms of
checkdowns to najee harris he had an
insane amount of receptions last year
with 74 receptions
and do i really think that he's going to
repeat that no but he's still going to
be incredibly integrated into the
offense and the quarterbacking situation
there it didn't look super bad last week
in the preseason game they've got some
options there so
i'm 100 okay with going with najee
harris
all right guys
let us dive into
the number eight pick
so
as we start the clock here there are
several options that we can still go
with again i talked about dalvin cook
and joe mixon
now it's super close here
and
the difference between dalvin cook and
joe mixon really for me
is that
dalvin cook is an incredibly high upside
player daven cook can technically you
know he could be the overall rb1 he does
have the skill set to do that in terms
of the workload that he gets on the
ground being the unquestioned
lead running back being in an offense
that we're going to see it's gonna be a
little bit different this year but it
should be a little bit more potent and
we've heard that he's going to get more
involved in the pass game as well
and again we've got an older running
back here he's 27 years old so we do
have a little bit of durability concerns
and the reason that dalvin kind of falls
backwards into this back half and not
typically
further up as you would normally see is
that
unfortunately
we know that he's going to miss three to
four games every single season and
that is a bit of a concern with him
unfortunately
so when i'm looking at dolphin cook
one of the things that i like to look at
is his overall stats and see if there is
some regression that is happening there
with him now the major issue that he had
last year is that he had touchdown
issues his touchdowns greatly dropped
from the prior year but i think he's
going to have some positive regression
and that's why i put him over joe mixon
because i think the upside is a lot
higher for him than joe mixon because
that offense can still heavily focus on
him and integrate him in the past game
so at the 108 i am taking alvin cook
now
let's see if we have got some comments
here uh
ross carter leonard fournette i love
leonard fournette
leonard is more of a second round pick
for me
i know it can be a little confusing
sometimes because leonard fournette had
a fantastic finish to last season and he
was an rb1 so arguably why would we not
be taking him within the top 10 of picks
because he could easily finish there
again and i agree with you
but um i feel like we have a lot more
safer options and i would prefer to take
leonard fournette kind of in the mid
second round range
we've got a comment here from charles
piss hawk uh cook greater than harris
cook greater than mixing
i agree with you cook greater than
mixing cook greater than harris
uh in terms of talent i agree with you
there
in terms of upside 100 agree in terms of
stability
and workload i think that harris have
has the upside there so i would prefer
to go with nadja harris there
stefan diggs quest our comment and
question on stefan diggs from jc
um diggs where are we taking him i love
stephanix we'll get into that in a
second um in terms of my wide receivers
um i tend to lean towards the top three
being
cooper cup justin jefferson jamar chase
and then when you get into that four or
five range between him and davonte adams
it kind of you know goes back and forth
but we'll get into that in a second
uh comment from
apio latte i would take aaron jones over
dalvin or naje
i don't disagree with you there um in
theory in terms of the potential upside
um
aaron jones has an incredibly high
ceiling this year we can talk about it
for a second because he's not in my
first round picks right here
unfortunately
love aaron jones but he's someone that
i'm taking in the either early or second
mid-round
so he's a fantastic option to come
around with maybe if you were taking a
wide receiver early if he could fall to
being paired up with where we were
taking cooper cup or
uh justin jefferson or maybe some of
these receivers that we're going to talk
about here in a second
uh aaron jones has an incredibly high
upside so i really love him this year
and then comment from yankees daniel
who is rb1 for the ravens it is going to
be jk dobbins um
even when gus edwards does come back and
he's injured right now um it's not
looking like he might not be ready for
week one but even when
gus edwards does come back jk dobbins is
the rb1 right there
all right guys
let's dive in because we've got some
more picks to make i'll try to get
through these quickly um
at the nine spot all right
we've had some running backs we've had
some running backs coming off and we're
going to probably kind of maybe stick in
that direction
we could go with one more running back
we could jump back into wide receiver
we've had a couple um we've got a couple
of good wide receiver options as well to
come off the board
here and
i think at the 109
i think we want to stick with running
back here and we're going to go with a
fantastic late round our late first
round value in the back half of the
first round at running back
joe mixon joe mixon is who i'm taking
here um if you are drafting back here
and you want to grab joe mixon
i talked about him before that he
doesn't have that same upside that a lot
of these guys that i'm uh
that a lot of these guys that i'm taking
before him have um he doesn't have the
same upside that they have because
unfortunately he is playing with jamar
chase and t higgins and they pass a lot
in that offense with joe burrow and they
command a lot of that attention and so
the workload in terms of that ability
for joe mixon to really get into that
top that top one two three of running
backs it's not really there he finished
last year as the rb4 in total points
but seventh in average points per game
so unfortunately for me i don't think
that it's possible for jill mixon to
eclipse
that rb5 territory because unfortunately
there's just not enough workload that
can go through
so joe mixon
that is the reason why he's not higher
up in the first round for me and why he
falls to the 109 pick now
at the 110.
here's where i'm diving back into
receivers
and it gets pretty exciting here because
we've got some fantastic options to go
with we've got
jamar chase we've got davonte adams we
got def on diggs we've got cd lamb too i
mean i know cd lamb is someone who
people get a little bit skeptical of in
terms of the consistency because when we
look at last year he wasn't incredibly
consistent in terms of his production
but amari cooper is gone sitting lamb is
the unquestioned wide receiver one there
so he falls into this category of guys
we can kind of take in this range
but
at the 110 i feel very confident in
going with
jamar chase
nearly
1500 yards last year receiving 13
touchdowns an insane rookie year
uh the only thing that separates him
from justin jefferson and cooper cup and
why they're those clear top two wide
receivers and why they go a lot earlier
than him
is the consistency and the presence of t
higgins
um as the one b to jamar chases one a
but jamar chase is extremely talented
and he's going to give you insane boom
weeks that can crush your opponent so
i will be taking him i'm going to jump
back to the comments real quick
you have the 10th p yeah you have the
10th pick and a 12 team league 100
um i like to go with um
i like to go with wide receiver here now
i will say that if any of those first
three running backs are those last three
running backs in cook harris or mixon
fall to the 10th pick
i'd probably go ahead and take those if
any of that value is flowing for you and
any of these guys are available later go
ahead and jump and take those pics um
but if not jamar chase is a fantastic
option at the 10th pick
and question from terrence roberts what
do you think about trevor lawrence i
obviously love trevor lawrence you guys
see the tiger paw
he is a fantastic i think he's actually
a fantastic option and uh superflex
leagues if you're looking for a qb too
because i like what i saw out of him
he's got some upside there and he does
get a ton of rushing yards on the ground
so
in my opinion he's not the worst option
to go with if you're looking at 2qb in
superflex leagues and then one more
question here from dipset donnie am i
crazy to think that kelsey is top 10
worthy you're not crazy you're not crazy
at all if you want to take kelsey
i would say
at the eighth pick is when i think
eighth pick to 12th pick is an
appropriate range for travis kelsey so
no you're not crazy at all if you want
to go ahead and jump in there and get
your man because it's never a bad idea
to start off with the fantastic option
of the number one tight end i know mark
andrews finished as the number one tight
end last year but i do think that travis
kelsey is going to reclaim his spot
all right guys
we've got a couple more picks right here
to go into
and let's uh let's dive into this
eleventh pick
and
let's go ahead and debate it out um
devonta adams or travis kelsey do we
wanna go wide receiver do we wanna go
with travis kelsey here
we just talked about him as a great
tight end option to be able to take in
the first round
personally
i think i'm going to go ahead and go
with devonta adams right here because i
know we've got some concerns with
receivers switching teams and that's why
devonta adams is falling back a little
bit behind some of those other top guys
that are a little bit more trustworthy
because we don't know exactly what kind
of production that we are going to be
getting
out of delante adams with derrick carr
but when you look at devonte adams the
talent is immense and derek carr is
actually a high volume passer
so i trusted a little bit more than you
might think last year um before the
henry rugs incident reeks one through
seven your car was actually the number
two in yards total yards behind tom
brady so the opportunity is there i
think that derek carr can keep devonte
adams as being a top five wide receiver
so that's when i'm okay with taking him
here at the 11th spot
now the spot i'm gonna wrap things up
guys because
i've been talking a lot um because i'm
really passionate about the first round
of the draft because there's so many
fantastic options here but let's talk
out this 12th pick here
because as we talked about there are a
couple of different directions that we
can go here
we've got
travis kelsey obviously just talked
about as the wider or the tight end one
if you want to go ahead and take him off
the board but
we have some other fantastic options at
receiver here you could go with stefan
dix he is a fantastic stable option that
you could go with i believe that he will
have a top five finish as a receiver
again you know he's going to be claiming
a ton of target share there from josh
allen the number one overall quarterback
so
stefan diggs is a fantastic option to
take here as well
then you get into some riskier picks you
could go running back and you could jump
into running back like
deandre swift deandre swift is also a
fantastic option if you want to get
risky if you want to get risky and take
a very high upside pick here because
deandre swift could finish off as the
rb1 overall i know it sounds crazy but
he was actually on a top five trajectory
last year top three trajectory last year
an average points per game so that's a
good option as well
so if you wanted you could go tight end
you could go wide receiver you could go
running back those are great
possibilities here but personally for me
i'm going to go tight end i'm going to
go ahead and get my guy the number one
overall pick at the 12th spot which is a
very fun position because you're
doubling up right here so you've got a
lot of flexibility but i'm going with
travis kelsey and i'll probably pair him
up as i come around the turn with a guy
like stefan dig
or deandre swift
travis kelsey again you know he is such
a fantastic option to take here because
he is now without tyreke hill
meaning that he is going to be the
unquestioned first look to patrick
mahomes now we've got some options that
have been filled in and i get that
you know there could be some guys that
maybe you know
don't really perform the way that they
need to and maybe we've got teams
doubling up on travis kelsey and they
give more attention to him and it makes
things more difficult for travis kelsey
but i do think the volume is still going
to be there he is still going to be a
fantastic option and i think that he's
actually going to overtake
and come back and be the tight end over
mark andrews this year so we're taking
travis kelsey out of the uh out of the
12 spot here
and we've got some comments here let me
dive into some comments um
i love this one we've got from vinnie
blast kelsey is gonna ball i completely
agree it is setting up to be a fantastic
year for him he is old but he is not
washed do not count out travis elsie
it's a great situation for him got a
comment here from dump set donner adams
without rogers will not be productive um
i get the argument for that but
i really do have faith that devonte
adams is going to still be incredibly
productive because he fills a very
specific role there in vegas vegas
really really struggled in terms of
touchdown production because they lost
timmy ruggs they then lost darren waller
towards the end of the year
they did have hunter renfro who
obviously i'm a big fan of filled in
admirably but unfortunately um they just
didn't have the options there to really
enhance their pass game and with davonte
adams there he is going to be the
automatic first red zone look for derek
carr so i really love him and think that
there's a very good chance that he again
finishes as a top five receiver
comment from ceo 911 not too high on
swift i get that as well but i'm really
sold on deandre swift if you look at his
2021 statistics um i think the first 11
games of the season he was a top three
running back in ppr and average points
per game the floor there is going to be
wonderful and the upside there is
fantastic and then one more comment here
from sam jack i like najee at the five
he's my number four back
um
i like najee as well once i get to the
five spot i just like to go ahead and
dive into those fantastic upside wide
receivers so that is my reasoning there
for pushing najee back behind those guys
alright guys really appreciate you all
joining in again this was a fantastic
fantastic crowd we went through our
ideal perfect first round if i were
taking
every single pick 1 through 12 how would
it shape out for me at the first again
we've got jonathan taylor
the smash rb1 overall after that i've
got austin eckler i've got faith for a
repeat there in his production
after that going with eric henry king
henry again when we look at the average
points per game that he had when he was
healthy last year 24.2 in ppr
he's a fantastic option as a top three
after that i'm finally diving into
christian mccaffrey i faded him a little
bit because he is a very risky pick in
terms of his injury history over the
past couple years but
you still have to have him in the first
round and once we get to that first spot
i feel a little bit more comfortable
with him at the fifth and sixth spot
we're diving into wide receivers and
going cooper cup and justin jefferson
and then diving back into relax at the
seventh with naji harris dalvin cook and
joe mixon they're jumping back to the
past catchers and going with jamar chase
davonte adams and then rounding up a
perfect first round
with travis kelsey again guys thank you
so much for watching this very awesome
first round
episode with bleacher report appreciate
you all joining in again my name is tara
roberts you can find me on twitter and
tick tock at its tare time and thank you
all
have fantastic fantasy football seasons